Welcome to Suburbicon, a town of
great wonder and excitement.
He-hey there!
Filled with the promise of prosperity for all.
Nicky, you need to get up. There are men in the house.
Son, there's something I have to tell you.
Those men killed Mom.
We've decided it'd be best if your Auntie
Margaret came and stayed with us.
Nicky needs a mother.
We'll be strong. We'll be fine.
Mr Lodge?
Yes.
You know a character named Rizzoli? He's a loan shark.
If you were into the mob for money, that
might explain what happened to your life?
Hi, pal.
This is the last time that clown's gonna ignore us.
Take care of the kid.
These animals took everything from us.
I have to make decisions like what's best for the family.
It's the police.
Any progress on the investigation?
A mobster got killed a couple of days ago.
I'm sorry for his loss.
Of life? Yeah, I guess he probably is too.
I'm here to collect.
What do you want?
I want all of it.
All of it.
Nothing like this ever happened here.
This is a safe place.
It was.
Would you like a cup of coffee?
I could have you killed in no time.
I could kill you too.